that's Gomez my Spain ha welcome to
citizen burger disorder
let's give my love it's a game about
friendship it's a game about hamburgers
here we are
all right tutorial make burgers serve
them burgers stuff is probably broken
it is absolutely broken report bugs okay
whoa Jesus what happened
okay I am a rogue robot destined to
serve burgers or leaves the meat oh
Jesus man I don't want to flip the bug
its main Jesus look-alike what are the
controls though all right well I better
just better start washing my hands there
we go all all nice and clean wash my ass
all right let's see her number for once
Jesus Christ that's what the [ __ ]
rats what are you doing with my burger
right get damn it oh that's not those
are not rats those are um
where they going anyway what's going on
out here
rats come back here I'll get you now get
you you son of a [ __ ] excuse me sorry
would you like a hug or a hamburger it's
a hug then it's a hug come here
this game is like Skyrim Jesus Christ
it's like you can do anything
oh is that my money stop stealing my
[ __ ] rats okay so it's left and okay
okay I got it I figured out I figured it
out uh-huh are you we gonna make a sale
for little burger but I better get a
real job they said oh god bouncy burgers
La Bam see burgers flip them burgers
whoo
this is how you flip burgers they're
really red though stop dancing burgers
Aaron is gonna put you back beautiful
number four we got a burger ready
a who ordered this delicious burger uh
all right there you go ma'am thanks for
the money huh thank you for giving me
money
got ya brats I'll get you one day I'll
get you I'm gonna [ __ ] murder you oh
oh hey there sorry that's don't worry
that's just our pets some say if the
meat looks like a hockey puck you
shouldn't need it
I say Yolo it's like an Oreo that's
great so this is my specialty I call it
cancer in a burger you got a problem
with my burger eat it eat it or get out
actually let's make out a nice look so
good what how did you do that
she stole my burger it's nutritious and
it's delicious so [ __ ]
Oh know what that is not a lead what is
this [ __ ] who thought I got dammit who
thought that was a good idea [ __ ]
all right let's let's hope they don't
realize better better Papa did it did it
did it to you here you go money money
make it rain make it rain make it rain
make it rain on them hoes slap that
booty slap that booty slap turbody but
don't hate thank you oh please come
again
where the [ __ ] is that what kind of name
is that
what the [ __ ] them burgers don't be
cooking what I we don't have any orders
huh did someone join me what an [ __ ]
look outta me so grumpy how was your
problem well I probably be that pissed
if I dat haircut like that so I'm
playing with someone else now this guy
is hardcore burger maker man where the
[ __ ] are you no no you're making him
bats
what did Ellen stop no what does he do
stop our intern is mentally challenged
now all our ingredients are a [ __ ]
dirty are [ __ ] dirty man it's okay I
guess we don't really have any cut
customers like it guess why
I'll go advertise good be naked sex say
it sells intern is what is intern doing
intern intern is he cleaning the dirty
dishes I'm sure you don't clean pretty
sure I'm not a hundred percent oh my god
this is so dumb
what am i doing this is the best
multiplayer experience of my life what
better way to bond
where's the [ __ ] costume worse not
even rats misses this place hey hey
there would you like some baguette yes
you do we have a customer good job haha
I'll get the room make sure doesn't
escape okay I'm trying but I can't type
this is our slave labor what is he doing
he had it that is bacon not [ __ ]
ropes now witchcraft just a dummy he's
still doing that he's still huh oh my
god
Oh for [ __ ] sake Jesus - rat burger oh
yeah oh my god that's tasty [ __ ] man
that's a great burger it's system oh my
god
now all customers would come maybe even
sell at birdies I swear when Kim comes
before a boot
read this burgers go straight to the ass
no there's another restaurant really you
gotta do what we gotta do
I'll get the bleach your [ __ ] I'm
getting the [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
Godric cuff huh they got a suffocate on
it
oh no he's gay all right let's see if he
wants this burger hey man you want a
free burger you want it eat it eat the
baguette god damn it
all right I'm gonna have to in the
episode there hope you guys enjoyed
watching I had a lot of fun
I still don't know what this game is
about but it's a lot of fun thank you
for leaving like I really appreciate it
bros and that's all for me for now stay
awesome best hi